what it's your boy ptoo the path we're
gonna do another stream of little
nightmares I've been wanting to play for
so long I I just got it
sorry it took so long for me to get a
video out if you're watching this
offline click the number in the
description it'll take you to when we
actually start playing [ __ ] I don't know
how loud this is this might be too loud
I did turn up the volume a lot before
okay how's it going live stream I just
had a lot of have a lot of fun last time
we played before but I want to finish
little nightmares it's been a while spin
a while boy I think it technically says
we were playing pray that's not good
yep and just everything did you guys
miss me
I bet you're dead I bet your DNA okay
little nightmares I really love this
game me and mites have been playing it
we got to the point where I am right now
so we're gonna we had to stop
I missed you like one of my french girls
that's not how it works
and what are you doing to the French
girls I actually never understood that
meme for the longest time until I
rewatched Titanic and I'm like oh he
draws her like cuz he draws french girls
naked oh I see I got it
hello and welcome back everybody
top of the morning to you all right good
good [ __ ] dream good life good living
the [ __ ] am i doing I was watching a
stream of let me see if I can find it
that was a guy spinning a fidget tool
for 24 hours but he was only on his
phone I thought it was pretty good I
mean really Who am I to criticize I mean
that's quality can't get better than
that
the [ __ ] soon I start someone just drops
[ __ ] 50 pounds on me it's your boy
Petey pie I love you I love strawberry
panties cheer you make my days better
whenever I'm feeling depressed any
chance you could sub to me or go to
Facebook or something Lucas who Stan
Lingle the one I'm sub to you buddy
comes up to your channel boy
Mitsy as vacant are you planning to play
any binding of issac that might be fun
it's been a while since we play that
that makes more sense for live streaming
as well welcome Mike is slam much
playing some team session one good [ __ ]
look it up what happened with the last
livestream I don't know I don't know
what happened you tell me you must be
tired after all this streaming tired
today I don't know what it is you was
live ours ago Western Hanlon hundred
subs please good luck on that Jimmy cui
oh my god thank you for saving me from
bored mph anytime 10 sir I love the
official podcast praise the cat ducks I
do know what you mean
it was weird we they started off the
livestream with that question like what
is your masturbation habit and I'm like
are they joking or are they serious I
can't tell guess what Peter pie I'm sub
to YouTube what thank you
hey Michelle allegory guerrilla 50 I
think you forgot to leave a message but
I appreciate it a lot facade facade Moda
bro I love bones but if I I'm glad you
did too it's good [ __ ] YouTube YouTube
everyone having a good Saturday
will you play def stranding it looks
like an interesting game I will
definitely play it L jlf thank you
Pierce you should DM me on Twitter I got
some video ideas
okay I have video ideas okay if I didn't
have video ideas put an upload videos
but it's not angry it's just like I
appreciate it I do it trust me
are they good ideas that's a completely
different question hi pizza will you
follow my food truck on twitter angie
burger sounds good if you come by bright
and i'll follow how about that inside a
deal sounds good
pills how can i donate well i used to
have a tip on on twitch but it's super
chat works well because then i know i'll
won't miss your man bun john again hello
sir great to see you again my birthday's
on the 30th of May I will be turning 15
please wish me an advance happy birthday
advance happy birthday Debra John I'll
be out the best time on your birthday I
hope you get a lot of gifts and I hope
you that's a wonderful time welcome 3 to
read HK hundred-dollar my god I could
retire big fan kids I love to interview
about your creepy and paranormal
experiences if you're ever up to it I
got some real little nightmares on my
channel darkness prevails what happens
on that oh it's like a creepypasta
Channel that's cool that's too spooky
for me but if you guys are into
creepypasta I check out darkness
prevails I am I don't really any like
experience like paranormal experiences
all I remember one thing was like when I
was really young I woke up in the middle
of the night and I swear I saw skeleton
because I remember it so clearly and
then it just like I couldn't move my
body was just frozen and then he went
and like touch my face but I can't
remember if it was real or not I was so
young steam powered gaming what do you
think of the new gorillaz album well I
really liked it but at the same time I
think it could be a lot better
I I don't know if it's it's not their
best album let's just say that I love
gorillas though I was very happy when
they reached out to me the mass family
adventures hey Pierce it's this [ __ ]
stand where they just talk for five
minutes which is not bad but doesn't fit
their live stream the marsh
familyadventure what is what is master
do run adventures they do pogo stick
fails and all kinds of [ __ ] hey thank
you for this family shadow you gave my
buddy the other day you rock that's cool
appreciate you guys you and Anthony
podila are my favorite youtubers are you
friends in real life I saw him on scare
PewDiePie ones he was some scare
PewDiePie season 2 Anthony is a really
good guy I really like him is Farley one
of the nicest youtubers I ever met in
person a quant appreciate you shrieking
hey piers can i get a shout out to my
youtube channel
there you go shrieking there you go
danish bro
almost relapse but you helped me stay
strong for years forever thankful
stay strong Katja kpop is life
appreciate you hey birds have been
substance priest to fine abrasive fauna
what the [ __ ] is that that's some
ancient Lord and there right there I
just hit 6k on Instagram I'm about as
giddy as it is way I'm about to give me
about it as you with your first hundred
oh that's cool that's not bad alright I
just kind of want to play so I'm gonna
turn off super chat and just play I've
been a huge fan for years keep up the
good work I love your new approach
you're taking on me guess that's cool
you guys are too nice
but let's play some Little Neck if you
guys want to join the go to gaming dot
youtube.com slash Porter Porter PI you
know what just so I don't have to
[ __ ] say it anymore
let's add a text can you do that on OBS
should take a second great how does that
look
nail it
and the last one is Calvin downs love
you in your videos can I can you shout
out kaseylee shout occasionally I guess
I didn't huh I didn't my bad
how are you guys doing today this fine
Saturday's what do you think is the best
song of the new gorillaz I guess
- and routine and wrote in it so I like
that song - it's really good
[Music]
you like you like this text is it just
ugly ugly I'll take it away it's - I I'm
gonna Samir this screen with a bunch of
[ __ ] all right
through this [ __ ] let's [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] please tell me if the game plays
too loud or too low
cuz that's the only way I know it's
playing right now you heard it there for
a second it seems a bit low I'll turn it
up
babbit a bit bit better but better it
makes more sense if I'm here I think
because there's a lot of walking to the
right or maybe not let's see
okay let me know if it's too low now
probably is okay
showed my porn folder Santa that's not
good
that's too [ __ ] low him for me
I'm assuming this is okay it's annoying
I can't really know for sure
I've been waiting days for this welcome
under new sponsors
okay let's keep playing um this will be
live I'm gonna try and really just focus
on the game what the [ __ ] just happened
stop showing my porn game goddamn [ __ ]
sake I can't here we are okay so this is
a zero def playthrough of me playing I'm
trying not to have the [ __ ] mouse on
the thing again little nightmares I've
been playing it a lot now like I said I
replayed it with Marzia and I died a lot
playing with my T I don't know why but
let's see if we can do this jump are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you serious
okay all right we're starting this video
now so you know whenever everyone
comments on the livestream videos when
the video starts it starts now
nothing has happened before this point
zero deaths until now okay we restart
[ __ ] piano man I'm going are you
kidding me I jump what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] [ __ ] now I'm just pissed off why
does he go from full screen what the
[ __ ] is happening here the lag is unreal
they're lagging for you guys i drinkin
it probably has like one of those thing
where like if you your game is tabbed
out everything else is lags alright
we're doing it like this now we're just
got to make sure that we don't die so if
this is your first time let me fix that
what is this now we are rich in
[ __ ] its life I don't even [ __ ] know
alright I'm quitting
I'm done I'm officially done what the
actual mother of [ __ ] [ __ ] god
damnit what is this what kind of
resolution is that there we go thank you
[ __ ] hell alright zero deaths from
now on the video starts now
hey how's it goin braucht my name is
Jeff welcome to little nightmares part
part 3 I believe we had just started
streaming if in case you saw what
happened before don't worry about it
okay
it's a completely new where are you oh
my god I thought I was the book nothing
bad has happened so far that's how you
jump apparently thank you for that I
realize now that we're starting a little
bit later than because we're gonna have
to do the there's a part here yeah we
have to get the crank and technically if
we already did it
okay um I know how to play this quickly
though cuz I did it Oh Mike never mind
never mind never mind
are you no don't make me jump
just leave me alone I'm a bookshelf why
are they always cranks in this game
that's a great question I'm getting
cranky that's why I love the enemy of
the game because he has super long arms
but he doesn't have it has a super short
peener I mean legs he barely has any
blanks so I know I noticed there was
like a lot more hidden stuff in the game
that I never really found like up here
there's a candle that I can lit or
whatever because it's lit but like what
is the point of letting the candles or
they just save stations or I still don't
really grasp what they do I found that
the best way to go through here is just
to run together so you won't really get
you
now he's coming he's coming he's coming
he's coming
go girl go hell yeah [ __ ] right
so here's the crank we've done this I
don't think he I don't think it goes in
unless you press that button but you
don't want to [ __ ] this part up that
movie is so creepy I figured are you are
you a boat in this and where are you on
a boat in this it really seems like it
because you know the waving back and
forth
[Music]
alright let's wait friend oh I'll just
go just go he's so creepy
[Music]
if he's blind then why does he have a
television let's see there's a candle
there [ __ ] it come on go girl I have no
idea where did that come on go go go go
okay crank it up crank it up boys it's
time to crank it up
that thing looks like you pierced thank
you very much domo arigato
reminds me of Pan's Labyrinth oh god
don't remind me of that [ __ ] go go go
no swing over here swing over here swing
over here you stupid piano I'm not gonna
[ __ ] this jump up Wow
[ __ ] you [ __ ] ha ha whoa
hell yeah we did it high five Shh that
was cool
okay officially never seen what happens
from this point but I imagine I'm gonna
grab this little finger
there are deaf everyone their deaf
playthrough of long nightmares I love
this game
it's such a fun puzzle game ok well that
was easy
please die thank you for the supportive
comments really appreciate you guys
always being so nice to me
very nice nailed it hell yeah okay
that's cool
this game is easy easy okay where are we
now Oh God love you pits thank you you
guys see some of you are nice I gotta
hand it to you some of you have a bit of
a soul oh my god Jesus Christ great okay
well you live in your learn
candles are for unlockables okay well
that was terrifying [ __ ] that guy he
really handed it to me yet randomly
grabbing stuff go ya miss me [ __ ] oh
god is he gonna appear again shut up
Edgar no Alexei oh god is he coming he's
come back
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up zero deaths
wait what I what's happening to the
gameplay oh that's so weird it's like
glitching out I hate him
slide slide in that DMC
hell yeah God oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
god damn it
Oh No Oh go up up up up up up up to the
top don't touch me zero Jeff you suck at
running thank you guys Oh God Oh what
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] don't touch me
don't touch me don't touch me
nope what a [ __ ] [ __ ] zero deaths
he keeps how long is his arms honestly
okay
come on crap why does it sound like a
[ __ ] fart how does he find me so
easily I supposed to grab the cage Wow
yeah I'm trying to but he's [ __ ]
hands are everywhere I'll say up here I
need to get the right timing here
okay now that's the time
grab it she's not grabbing it what the
[ __ ] oh my god that's so annoying smash
the cage like that's someone you're
right then with the corner in the corner
okay that makes sense
there we go okay got'em oh never mind
okay so anyway it's zero def playthrough
here doing really well
I really feel proud of my
accomplishments
okay all right well that was easier than
it should have been shut up guys I need
supportive comments here don't be a
hater 9 that's okay thanks
come on yes
oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] his arm fell off
oh my god no oh oh oh hell yeah oh yeah
man look at that [ __ ] what that's [ __ ]
up hell if you notice when he gets you
he never actually kills you I had this
theory that he's actually nice or
whatever he's just taking care you know
cuz he was taking care of the babies in
the game I don't know he never liked
when you when you get killed it's not
like he kills you he just haunts you cuz
I feel bad for him slap that like button
right now for Sarah - playthrough I
can't believe we're doing this Sarah -
that's pretty impressive pretty good
pretty good
it's just a theory
a game theory let's keep on rolling
everyone good thing I have this rain
jacket he's a vegan that is another
theory oh oh we got hooks we got hooks
and we got dead bodies let me go let me
smash ah [ __ ] I missed let me smash yeah
yeah boy are those meat hooks I think
they are
hey great this game just became
half-life - how about that there's the
chef he's I'm gonna smoke Oh No we
played this part before [ __ ] it's a lot
of bodies here have you guys seen chef
by the way
it's a good good movie it's about a man
on a food truck I don't know to each his
own
okay we're hungry again I don't
understand this whole Hungary segment
cabbage I'm actually allergic to cabbage
can't eat it
makes me fart that's more intolerance
then oh don't tell me we're gonna eat
the rat that's [ __ ] up I'm not doing
that [ __ ] hey did Sylvain just join as a
sponsor he designed that that's cool I
appreciate this till then he did the day
icon if you spawned become a sponsor he
created it and he's also the art guide
for tuber simulator and legend of the
brofist very cool [ __ ] welcome Oh
disgusting tastes great lovely and being
vegan it's my favourite yes
also when I've joined a sponsor and get
a cool icon like stolen hash go to
gaming youtube.com you can join the chat
we can chat about eating rats and [ __ ]
man I love the style of this game it's
so [ __ ] cool and I push this yes/no
guess I can
I think cabbage makes everyone fart well
sorry if we're thinking I'm special for
a second there let's see what the chef
is cooking maybe he has something better
for us oh wow
blood trails that's that that's always a
good sign isn't it
see see we're definitely on a boat
things are moving on their own and [ __ ]
just Edgar eat nothing good cabbage yes
yes that will be a yes oh boy here it is
hey look a carrot delicious you're
coming with me carrot you're my new best
friend your name is Kenny we're gonna do
a hundred percent playthrough where the
Kenny the carrot will never let you go
off [ __ ] this I love the design of this
guy he's so [ __ ] creepy
it's literally me after I'm done with
YouTube
the fish looks so cool as well I love
this part oh it scares me
okay he sounds like an elephant come on
Kenny come on Kenny we got this I'll
[ __ ] we're going for it I remember where
you run alright this is the end Kenny
I'm sorry I love you but you got to go
distract them Kenny oh god what do I do
now catch this oh god can you reach me
mr. short catch [ __ ] and oh no I need
that
oh [ __ ] come on are you doing down there
buddy whoa what you gonna do [ __ ]
okay lit the lantern right what do I do
that thanks to all the new sponsors okay
what do I do
jump oh I can't make the jump okay I
didn't Jesus Christ woman calm down easy
now easy does it
let's not [ __ ] this up
okay what do we have here at least he
can't [ __ ] grab me hey catch Vic's oh
yeah you man but what you gon do fight
there huh what you gonna do
zero depth if you're watching this live
stream now I just know it's there
definitely so far we have not died a
single time
all right let's claim this dead fishes
very nice it would make sense for the
fishes to be here as well if we were in
a boat you know I'm saying you know I'm
saying you know he's gonna Haul Jeff
you're back I love you you come with me
Jeff I missed you you're my lover have
you guys ever oh the other Jeff is
coming after me Jeff no no no you're the
wrong Jeff and we need this Jeff okay
so I think here's like optional to find
the potato man or whatever cuz that's
another thing I notice we might say you
can actually like catch them and it
let's see they hide from you yet to find
them oh my god oh my god oh my god no no
no no I [ __ ] up [ __ ] up brush I
[ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up [ __ ] up [ __ ] the big time
out of come out of him in oh my god [ __ ]
the potato guys [ __ ] fine enough
hell no oh my god zero desk
Oh are we back here
or are we somewhere else we're back here
[ __ ]
that doesn't help yeah I forgot Jeff
Nilus sneaked it sounds like it's on to
the right I need a key okay
I forgot the key huh I forgot the key
that's all right
I'll find the key - cut there it is
okay we got it you think I can reach it
I can't dangle dangle dangle and dangle
see dangling solves all the humanities
problem I don't think a lot of people
realize I think you can hide under the
bed I think so too but right now I'm
kind of a puss
we're gonna go I'm just gonna go for it
I'm just gonna go for it okay so where
does the key go
where does the key go potato man do you
know what the key goes what the [ __ ] are
you doing neck potato man got them see
you can grab them and we're like a
mushroom II you just give him a hug
that's cute dangling doesn't solve all
problems Pepsi you can't touch me
[ __ ] got like AI has an amazing
neck okay there's a door at the end of
the kitchen I figured as much
maybe we could save Ken after all okay
Skiba d bap
Skiba disco I got a key kind of keying
you
Skiba nice got bad but D be they do I
would put this key inside of you Oh God
it sounds like a heavy smoker just get
that feeling you know oh god he's there
okay just got a sneak past him you know
the key here is to not make any sounds
at all you know
don't touch mr. fish don't touch anyone
I'm just gonna go friend [ __ ] this oh
god don't touch anything
there you go oh my god he ate Ken he
[ __ ] ate Ken where's Ken
goddamnit oh I just make a a sausage
Hey nice you're not my new best friend
I'm calling you
family-friendly Felix oh I like the
sound it makes
it's very sexy chefs are pretty health
unhealthy in general they seem like they
have a rough job to be a chef you know
me can I use this hey it's the sausage
again oh I see we have to go through
here oh jeez I have a strong feeling
we're not a it's it's family friendly
Felix again here with a giant sausages
it's bigger than me
it's literally bigger than me I like it
though oh yeah this is the part where
you have to make sausage isn't it love
making sausage it's my favorite yes
we need more of them missing I think we
need more of them oh so cute a tiny
little elevator I want one of these in
my house okay perhaps we can go here oh
wow this looks like a nice place but
let's let it up fam hey it's mom goodbye
so it's the point of being here
is it just a safe station or
or can I grab these it's hard to see
it's so dark here we go
oh my god what am I looking at here [ __ ]
I [ __ ] up okay let's try that again I
think this is kind of like a bonus bit
no let me get up there
I don't know
it's a potato man there I want to give
him a hug
well I guess you can't hug everyone I
love cats a lot of potato people I love
every kind of potato people I just want
to hug them all but I can't can't hug
and see what I say about the dangling
guys what I say huh what I [ __ ] say
men [ __ ] okay maybe I was wrong
yeah hey we got one
[ __ ] okay grab it oh it's heavy I got to
push it okay push that meat there we go
nice nope go in the hatch
hey go buddy I think we need one more oh
there it is
you should hug us since then why would I
ever think of doing that what's wrong
with you guys I'm fingering pewds under
his camera great all right I'm gonna do
later streams from now on because those
comments a plus a plus on those comments
okay
welcome to the sponsors the powerful
burrito if you want to become a sponsor
as well go to gaming
jutsu comm slash p2p and become a
sponsor you can join the chat and
support me I really appreciate it
alright let's let's make some meat boys
yeah boy yeah that's my Ainslie
impression yeah boy I love it see what I
say about the dangling huh
what I [ __ ] say about that dangling
boys that's right
I'm not afraid to say it dangling solves
all problems all problems in life family
friendly Felix here by the way guys if
you're ever in a bad situation just make
sure you dangle
I don't trust this at all by the way
[ __ ]
okay we're clearly gonna hide here later
I ain't down with that that means he's
gonna come up here later
we need another [ __ ] key I have a
strong feeling he's gonna yep I think I
remember it go in please thank you that
guy looks like he's having a rough life
I almost feel bad for him hey he's got
some cheese that looks fresh depending
on the cheese of course the cheese that
stuck between my ass that's that's some
bad cheese is it me or was he not really
touching that me
it's got a bowl sack hat my name it's
okay let's go down
[ __ ]
this is just to hide I think it is
yeah
he's breathing very heavily I like it it
turns me on nothing about this kitchen
is sanitary what are you talking about
it looks awesome that looks delicious
are there two cooks I do think so yeah
they didn't want this one looks a bit
different with me yeah too many cooks
too many cooks too many cooks too many
cooks ignore me ignore me
oh [ __ ] I missed it
see he doesn't hurt me as well zero
deaths technically zero deaths
suppose I'm I was supposed to go behind
him seems like a safer option doesn't it
it looks like the amnesia monster he's
eating them nation monster oh god I
think he sees me what are you gonna do
that hahahaha
what you gonna do that bar huh [ __ ]
come get a box oh [ __ ]
ah that shouldn't count he'd sound like
an elephant I agree he does what if
you're just a runaway child on this boat
I don't think so it's why are we so tiny
oh he really sticks his face in there
he's a good chef
what happens if we press this
I think the key came out didn't they his
head looks like a ball sack well ain't
nothing wrong with that
zero chefs everyone well there's the key
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh that's that's not good
okay all right that means we have to
pull can we do that again
gotta get that gotta get that gotta get
that key chichi grab that [ __ ] please
grab that [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
come on boy come on boy hell yeah hell
yeah man that's awesome man yeah
Sarah that's everyone zero deaths okay
we got to hurry up we got to hurry up
cuz he's coming right after us put it in
put it in put it in put it in put it in
put it in food is hope oh god he's
coming dough
you [ __ ] ho sorry I need to call you
that dough goodbye [ __ ] Wow Wow my
goodness my damn i threw a can oh geez
ah geez just the tip guys just the tip
zero deaths everyone
okay well clearly we need to grab this
why aren't you grabbing it no what am I
doing here why the cans
oh I can grab these I thought I couldn't
okay there we go
Hillary Clinton
zero deaths Sarah def playthrough we're
doing good doing really good oh he's
doing the dishes can we can we use these
oh my god oh my god what is happening I
wasn't straight up tap dancing right
there okay we're here now why did they
all look the same
oh sorry I just realized it's not too
happy on this two of them
thanks two of them confirm oh jeez okay
all right
where can I run here
can't touch this can't touch this can't
touch
oh god he's fast he touches boy are they
wearing masks no I think they're
actually are just that ugly I know it's
incredible welcome all the new sponsors
appreciate you guys if you want to
become a sponsor and support me and join
the chat go to gaming dot youtoo.com
slash piggy bank
slash cruder pi and if you want to yell
at me being [ __ ] at games that's okay
that's alright I don't know why I'm
doing this but I'm doing it probably
shouldn't have done it
why did I just do
I should press the dish everyone there's
some word apparently that's I want to
break the tension in the game but it's a
pro grade son
yeah it just seemed like a little bit
like Alice in their own Wonderland okay
we can climb here right now doing
push-ups
hey-ya pull-ups so I just changed the
direction of this okay maybe we can jump
on it later
okay go in grab the hook yeah but I know
I need to grab the hook
I just need to get to the hook to grab
the hook
I think treating me like I'm some pest
or something
zero deafs everyone don't get caught you
know now keep keep saying obvious [ __ ]
to me that really helps [ __ ] I can't get
up there
this is so stressful I mean I'm not even
playing climb the trays in the first
room okay I figured I had to go all the
way back cuz it was kind of almost too
easy
oh god don't look at me
[ __ ] sounds they make that ass yes
but no for me that's what I'm talking
about they are sexy
there's no denying how sexy they are
I mess up a pussy-ass I make it look six
[Music]
American Luke 6 okay so there should be
hugs right too many hooks too many hoops
there's no hooks [ __ ] you guys lied to
me
[ __ ] I don't actually don't know
I don't think you guys would actually
lie to me should I climb in the middle
oh these plates I should climb these
plates wait
oh [ __ ] actually got me ain't tough on
me oh my god that's disgusting
it's weird because I couldn't climb
anything else
okay
there we go
what's making that [ __ ] sound this is
it this is [ __ ] it go go go go go by
bit oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah ah ah ah ah baby [ __ ]
ha ha what you gonna do what you gonna
do when I dangle on you
hell yeah that's what I'm [ __ ]
talking about
bye [ __ ]
you can keep your chin to yourself boy
oh oh oh oh sorry denied [ __ ]
slide oh he can reach for me that's why
they got me before oh [ __ ] oh no
bye [ __ ] ah zero deaths everyone I
[ __ ] up there and I [ __ ]
keep going oh my god he's throwing wine
at me he's wasting wine hey I got
bubbles on me ha ha bye bye [ __ ]
and I'm look at my legs what this wait
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ]
what a shame
[ __ ]
come out come out come out
why did he let go [ __ ] it out I did not
let go
let it go ow guess you had to dangle
afterward the negatives three deaths
that's right that's right that's that's
what we got right now doing good doing
good brush all right cool
my name is chef this is cool I like this
era I think we're just done with the
chefs now so I think the third I'm just
guessing I don't know it's the third
enemy of the game will up here we should
I think we saw earlier which is the
grandma well maybe I'm wrong
number one gamer on YouTube Rose
oh god that's a long ladder
I'm loving this game I love it too it's
a really cool this game
here we go ah oh that's bright we are on
a boat yes
I call that [ __ ] what did I [ __ ] say
huh what I [ __ ] say huh yes maybe it
was obvious what is happening here
we got boarded oh my god
[Music]
[ __ ] hell dude it was obvious okay
well sorry it's so cool I love the art
style of the game
really feels like you're in an adventure
okay we're in
oh wow are those two people on the boat
huh I very attractive people in this
universe
they look like meatballs I want to eat
them I'm going I'm going to eat them I
hope it nice okay I think that's the
same right there
I think that's a saber right [ __ ]
there
should we do a quick little break I'm
getting a little hungry in place give me
a give me a quick break I'll be right
back okay just give me one my name a
Jeff
just give me one hi Jeff and I'll be
right back
I got a P I gotta get her snack you
should do the same and we'll keep
playing this [ __ ]
you
praise the Lord
not me I just found that I just found
coffee
we've been out of coffee for the longest
time and I've been so tired I got coffee
now I should be all good
ah am I still here can you guys still
like no point that I'm back good stream
I guess he's back now I would give a
[ __ ] yeah and I got some flapjacks some
protein flapjacks what else do you need
or mouth at now I got a reaction took
you guys a while
a few minutes and then we'll keep
playing but not pop-tarts you guys want
some anise tomorrow but that was
probably terrible ah
this coffee man [ __ ] heaven oh let's
call it oh my god 50 from it's your boy
PewDiePie Activision Trump please [ __ ]
up soon so we get ideas for cod could
you comment on one of my bits it'd make
my year alright thanks right now
I wrote a blog post or I'll go about why
my name is
I'm a god the chat is exploding welcome
all the new sponsors hotdog levy Tremmel
and Tommy Anderson welcome to the fam OD
what kind of snack did you guys get
welcome Gina arakawa Robyn thank you bad
boy
music by rom coming here to relax and
drive with me through mountain canyons
and peaks as we listen to game music
radio in my latest dashcam video let's
ride is that the videos you make or what
is that I know you talk about but yeah
count me in welcome Patrick welcome
Thomas welcome day I'm going to VidCon
I'm gonna to see you there
I'm not going a bit [ __ ] I'm not going
to VidCon sorry you won't see me there
if you go to VidCon hate to let you down
Thank You Benjamin Thank You Priscilla
thank you jack Thank You Samantha
thank you tall boy Thank You Mickey
Mickey room
hey another one from big one from Oh
Mega Buster hey please give the stream a
lap dance how about I just show my tits
or one teddy there you go
guess you guys are into kinky [ __ ] humph
hey boots just want to say you're
helping a lot with my exciting I'm not
over it but it's nice to have a place to
forget you know also you stream on my
birthday and you didn't even say happy
happy birthday happy birthday you're
soft cookies I'm glad my videos hot it's
a milk in this just made me all [ __ ]
up no no it's a bad flapjack right there
yeah I think I'm dying welcome Sarah
Murphy welcome Ethan Castle if you want
to join the famine go into gaming dot
youtube.com slash Peter Pan and I'll let
you suck on my titties welcome Russian
I'm not allergic I'm just intolerant
okay I think everyone is intolerant to
meth or most people are okay yeah [ __ ]
me up alright let's keep playing
Thank You Aaron Brown thank you all the
spacers oops
moved the wrong one there we go play
roblox I'm not gonna play roblox calm
down I'm gonna play it and once we hit a
million subscribers then I'll play
roblox 24/7 all right we back uh just
making sure everything is working sorry
welcome evil gorilla alright here we go
I don't think there's we're doing a zero
playthrough of this game by the way in
case anyone now wonders if you're new
I'm a pro gamer
they call me Beast Master 64 right I do
a lot of a lot of a lot of zero game def
playthroughs so far was sailor deaths in
this game play it's pretty incredible we
have not died a single time
hey look it's jacksepticeye's family but
that came out a lot meaner than I meant
it to be I didn't mean to bring his
family into this hey look it's my family
I take it back it's anyone's family ok
moving on great great I think this shows
that jacksepticeye a meme needs to die
ok
Hey look it we're in the luxurious
quarters maybe maybe this is like a
behind the scenes of Titanic this game
Oh like they're all hungry and [ __ ] I
wasn't expecting this look very sexy I
like it
[ __ ] it come on
uh-huh oh okay oh [ __ ] me oh my god he
ate me what the actual [ __ ] zero deaths
that was terrifying [ __ ] up man
you [ __ ] seal it's crawling after me
stop it go [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's not done yet hey guys stop
it I'm on it to you laddies my name is
jacksepticeye don't mind me guys I'm
just going here ah [ __ ] come closer
please
oh come closer not the fat lady I kind
of fingers is that all god I can't wait
to get my hands on that [ __ ] alright
let's just dangle what I say about the
dangling bros what I say about the
dangling I said it but she's about to
break her [ __ ] neck Jesus Christ my
name is Jeff this is so cool this part I
love it
what'd I say about the dangling though
while I say about the dangling though
hey ho dangling know my name is Jeff
excuse me
I jump too far maybe we need to push it
maybe not all right let's get going I
know that I know I can get a potato
people there don't come after me I am
very fragile no eat your food your foot
I thought I would push this down or some
[ __ ] look at his face you're so creepy
no [ __ ] their necks Haley he just sliced
me like a big old fat [ __ ] man I don't
like it I want a bagel now why would you
comment that out of all things I want a
[ __ ] babe I'm going for the paper for
Tippit's potato man right now
what that I should echo what she knew
why he had let it let it fam hey can I
get a hug that's right you get a hug so
cute that's adorable peace out brother
I'm going through sometimes I remember
I'm live-streaming and I can't actually
say a bunch of [ __ ] that I can't
normally say okay let's go don't touch
me don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me you nasty you [ __ ] you nasty
ash ah [ __ ]
who eats who shoves their old hand in
their mouth when they e welcome at the
otaku great name
what am I doing wrong here I'm clearly
doing something wrong
this is like the bathhouse scene with no
face I weary watch that movie recently
it's so good spirited away
it's so [ __ ] good I'll never get sick
of that movie I just don't touch me
remember if it does jab lucky I fell for
the same guy cuz it looks like the
bottom guy is really gonna get me a Thai
bird I love your face there's a Italian
buffet alright there's an if Chinese
buffet in Italy it's so [ __ ] good all
you can eat man how are you
the message here is really bad Greek it
does seem a lot like greedy its greed is
their [ __ ] I need to be more patient
greed is really the theme of spirited
away something I noticed
he was really loved getting eaten out
thank you AG car welcome welcome train
what am I doing wrong here am i doing it
wrong
clearly I'm doing it wrong this part is
easy
what the [ __ ] it's the only way to get
through that I'm [ __ ] up big time here
why is this here
jump I have to jump I guess that makes
sense
let me try that I am not stopping Oh
jump really helps Wow okay you guys
weren't kidding alright alright sorry
sorry about that one that was cool
probably my fault but hey top of the
morning to you I'm a pro gamer I know
how it's played I know how to play games
guys I don't know about you guys but I I
know what if they games I play games
every day just anyone want some wine I
saw such as mind though oh no sausage ah
that's just sad
sausage didn't do anything today they
really like eating on this boat
guess I guess they like eating guys no
no no no [ __ ] I'm not it ah you're
disgusting
oh my god that was close
god damn this place [ __ ] hit this is
making me hungry I'm gonna eat before
this god Dan oh oh it's a flappy one
it's a flappy one I regret everything in
life now hahaha - fat boy hey you want
some wine with that [ __ ] can I climb on
his ass hell yeah sanim go go what did a
shooter but a bit longer what Jim
god I'm sorry but I know people I got
annoyed with December but that was worth
it that was [ __ ] awesome zero deaths
everyone
oh sure you see coming after me I think
he's coming after me oh no no no no he
saw me oh this is bad we gotta hide fast
okay whoa are we gonna see him take a
[ __ ] Oh sad I was really hoping Oh Jeff
Jeff ma'am man where you been
brah come back here buddy Jeff please
Jeff don't hide don't be scared but I'm
scared hey Jeff come out come out and
play
you're a toilet paper we're supposed to
have fun together
and this is where you belong how [ __ ]
let me do that again
and this is where you belong no you keep
throwing at the mirror you're ruining it
and this is where you belong Jeff what
are you white why do you you don't
belong in the mirror here the belong in
the toilet he keeps throwing to the
toilet no matter what I think it's cuz
I'm supposed to break the mirror yeah
that that I just discover the puzzle by
[ __ ] around with toilet paper oh my
god okay all right then
oh that's good that's real [ __ ] gay
told you guys I'm a pro gamer I know how
to play games that though the old toilet
paper trick y'all know know about it
[Music]
that's some good [ __ ] right there oh
[ __ ] I almost fell down are there
there's some kinky [ __ ] in the other
room all right
we could jump down here and get the mom
sent you but nah oh okay well I guess
yes oh we are supposed to jump down here
cuz we're getting the elevator this is
almost exactly like inside it's
incredible ha similarities I was
thinking this game it it really tells
the story through just looking at the
world and going through it and it's
really exactly like a lot of other
stories I really like like blood-borne
and especially my favorite manga which I
talked about before like Blaine it's
really just about a guy walking through
this giant [ __ ] mega structure and
you don't know much at all but that's
what makes it so interesting and that's
why I love it so much so I really love
this way of storytelling it's so
interesting and you may not even get
anything at all the first time you read
it but it makes the replayability and
reread a bit I guess so much more
interesting I think instead of a story
shove into your face obviously whatever
keep playing okay oh my god what the
actual [ __ ] is that thing what this game
just became spirited away what the [ __ ]
is that why is it wearing a mask
it's very Japanese isn't it with the
shoes and everything why is this game
Japanese solar started
this is spirited away chase scene but
they keep going they're so fun go Felix
family friendly village here my name is
Jeff the name is Jeff yes that was
awesome
that was so cool also remember to go to
gaming dot youtube.com slash PewDiePie
and hit sponsor me oh my god that was
awesome
hell yeah that's an airhorn right
[ __ ] there why is there hat here
finds the boat Japanese maybe they just
thought it was cool it is cool I like it
oh [ __ ] we're hungry again
alright we'll find a snack
we'll find a snack ok
- fine - snake yeah one of them fell off
in Solaris welcome crazy pyro pyro
welcome welcome our looks kept here
have you tried Indian buffet I have not
is it good
oil sausage thank you buddy
no no yeah that's right give it to me
give it to me no what's our sex what's
wrong with you what's wrong with you I
don't like you anymore
okay I don't like you anymore [ __ ] you
what the actual [ __ ] it let's just
perfectly fine sauce it's right there
how could you do this how could you do
it here you go buddy
I'm sorry and sorry I had to eat you
it's really hungry
there you go rest in peace I I think I
think I'm an [ __ ] I it's just a guess
it's the wild guess I think I'm an
[ __ ] they don't eat the people you
hug I think oh there's mom
she looks pretty hello mom hello mother
I'm sure she's harmless do you know
potato people taste better than sausage
now I didn't know that no one gave me
that memo I guess I'll have to try it if
we have to throw to get the lay looks
happy though his name
hey we had one shot to do that [ __ ] I
feel like we should hide ok we're fine
how's this game gonna end
oh boy this is getting intense I'll open
the tipping after we're done if you guys
want to do that ok this is so cool I
were loving this game gets better and
better
ok so this is what we saw earlier in the
game we saw this room I thought it was a
grandma but I guess it's just a mom mom
a Mima all that is creepy mannequins
we got to find another key
who has a [ __ ] picture framed of a
goddamn pig amazing bastion with a
humming
oh mama mama please don't eat me welcome
Sombra is she harmless
what do we do mom
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa she has
superpowers what what does it happen
what just happen
what's happen I died okay good I mean
not good I didn't dies there are deaths
I just mean
the closet run [ __ ] run
well it ain't that easy don't call me a
[ __ ] admit it Meredith okay what I do
here
[Music]
okay just sneak okay mind the mannequin
or sneaky
we're sneakin I like the humming it's
beautiful
make noise great tip guys great tip god
I love this game
sorry it's been a while since I jump on
a bed
just felt like it was my duty okay
what's happening here
so she insta kills you like if she sees
you you're done basically so what do we
do here the ways as a distraction
perhaps yes that will do quite fine but
I should push it push it
she's not pushing it anymore there's the
car just don't let her see us Oh welcome
Thais Leopold welcome as a bro as a plus
bro
as a up broad the key is in the mirror
the [ __ ] are you saying it's right there
she just got quiet that's creepier I
think she knows where we are that's okay
I ain't scared think I'm scared I never
get scared
okay all right now let's be very careful
I suggest you
where is she my god where the [ __ ] is
she I don't like this bro where the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] I'm trying to listen very
carefully I also realized there's one of
these here I might as well write hope
she won't mind oh [ __ ] okay probably
should not have done that probably men
they should not have I done that I had
to turn the sound off cuz this is too
stressful guys it's fine she's fine
we're fine she just left that's what you
do when you hear a vase cracking right
you just go away okay sneaky dish new
sneaky Disney I like to sneak sneaky DB
sneak get a snack sneak Kitty sook
sneaking a snoot guy I do better Boop
okay all right here we go there's the
beautiful picture of that pig again my
god it's sexy that [ __ ] that pig sorry
was I did I say that out loud okay
that's all right that was a joke
although I've been with some girls you
know what I mean okay
let's be careful now I'm ruining it I'm
not reading the chat cuz everyone is
yelling spoilers so [ __ ] that here we go
okay what's gonna happen I have no idea
what's gonna happen I'm really nervous
I think we're towards the end here okay
okay I'm just gonna run for no reason at
all
she's one of the mannequins Asian she ah
[ __ ] just run run mama run run mama mama
mama see the run
mama mama run run run run and slides
through the D and [ __ ] ah ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
that dog hell no why is this place
haunted all the [ __ ] inside and what's
with all the mannequins man I don't like
I got one other thing in my throat oh my
god run run run run run run run run
Kaiba can't go there that's okay that's
okay welcome Carl appear clear
a great time to join the chat [ __ ] oh my
god
this is actually kind of stressful isn't
it oh I see I burp when I'm stressed out
I can't help it come on buddy
okay what are we doing here there's
nothing here [ __ ] okay what do I do
there's nothing here it ain't nothing
really
hey you don't stop the Phillies so I can
get my mind of this yellow back
widely still alive I don't know go
figure mean Wow
okay here we go nice okay we did it I
don't know I didn't see that that was
obvious what is this whoa it's a mirror
I'll show her how ugly she is excellent
that should do the trick
hey lady hey lady you ugly fish guess
what hey [ __ ] ah [ __ ] okay fish you
ugly get up get up get up get up get out
of my head and hold the mirror in her
face instead okay I'm gonna go to the
light
there are that there that guys come on
[ __ ] come on guys we can do this come on
boys and girls
you can't tell a lady she's ugly right
to her face that's just rude I would
never say it to her face but she is very
ugly you know I'm probably tell her
through Amazon Zahra Deaf's everyone
come on stay in the light
just stay in the light and let the [ __ ]
in the wall all right hey guess what
ugly pro-gamer everyone we've only dined
we only died six times I mean nothing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing run oh my god you
[ __ ] up that's what you did all right
miss you ugly god damn it Sarah deafs
come on we got this
where's the line there it is
show me your Chili's
oh she's she's she's arousing me come on
[Music]
how many times do I gotta tell her this
is so creepy this is intense man
we have the same floor in our flag too
now don't tease me girl don't tease me
stop teasing me Oh what is wrong with
our faces is it the [ __ ] Sun or we've
died zero times
stop stop counting him inside she never
gives up hun nope oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we did
it we did it we did it oh my god
zero deaths everyone okay all right
let's stop her we got to stop her
nope that's mine that's mine
it's mine I'm really hungry don't tell
me I'm gonna eat her I'm not I don't
know I'm not down with that excuse me do
you mind if I have a little snack on
your neck oh that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ]
[Music]
whoa oh my god we could have eaten her
ass
there's more fat there
we gained her powers now
oh [ __ ] dog
that's why we eat them who was that it
no this morning
what's happening oh okay
whoa
this is so cool
are we gonna [ __ ] all these hungry ass
[ __ ] up
yeah we are
oh my god God um anyone else you want
some that's right you don't [ __ ] with me
oh my mind
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
all right we're killing all of them
aren't we
[Music]
can we please kill
the chef's name is that all Adam like
here we go the eye is revealed it opens
the door
yes Wow
[Music]
just wow
such a cool game
[Music]
really love it
gg gg guys hey there's a potato guy is
he saying bye are they coming with me
they're so cute by
I'm guessing this is the end yet
okay wonderful
what a game hard as it is really didn't
credit a job sweet look this looks like
Swedish names
I'm gonna guess they were Swedish good
on you appreciate you
maybe Nordic or something that's
incredible
they really did an amazing job this game
was so good if you guys enjoyed this
please go and support the game and check
it out yourself I think you'll really
really enjoy it it really is a pleasure
to play it pleasure to play it for you
bros especially doing it live it's very
fun I enjoy doing these and I know some
people maybe doesn't like the fact that
I'm a little distracted by the chat but
I think it's a fun interactive
experience Simona bruschetta yeah that's
definitely Swedish names here that's
cool I guess inside it was made by
Danish people and this game is to be
able to switch people it's very cool
very impressive what they make I don't
mind at all that it was a little bit
shorter I know some people almost hate
shorter games but it's the story I guess
and they this is how they wanted to tell
it and I really appreciate it
it's really cool one of the best games I
probably one of the best games I played
this year for sure for sure easy easy
very impressive can't wait to see what
else kind of games these guys will make
in the future really hope this game does
well and people buy it and stuff like
that I'd be really cool
[Music]
is there an after credit scene fit like
he's worth worth checking out anyway
see if there's anything after the
credits
[Music]
again I'm a blend soup
the game is little nightmares
it's not steam
[Music]
well then credits are 30 minutes long
hey thanks for the stream you're just
happy I will continue to reporter you
cheers mate Omega bar you're so nice
appreciate you
why do you guys enjoy this
that's a very long credits sales manager
okay yeah we're getting there
Danmark sweden finland community manager
come on come up wrap it up hey Lee hello
that guy it's a cool guy
all right many seen at the end but
credits well we're gonna sit through it
[Music]
hey Shawn respawn official hey Pitts
then if you remember me from hell I do
remember you can you check out my
channel and give me tips oh I'll be sure
to do that
that's might as well watch it here check
it out well you got over his sub that's
not bad
I like your background very markiplier
ish I don't know what to say just having
fun with it I years ago I didn't enjoy
your content it felt incredible wish
there was a video you may be asked what
you should do to that or respond to
telling you do what you love la that's
cool thank Dan hey piers it took me six
months watching you subscribe you got me
with your don't put this in your mouth
intra bad [ __ ] video really Jane Kat
hey Felix you want to say you mean a lot
to me and sense that if you if it
weren't you for you Marc or Jack I don't
know how I'd say go and love you stay
awesome you guys are so nice remember
when I was like I yeah it's it sucks
like going through its years I'm glad
that to get see that Oh watching mine my
channel thanks for the stream how long
are you gonna stream it's 25 degrees and
I'm dying 25 degrees is extremely hard
for Sweden what the [ __ ] is happening
over there squid nugget but you can't
say my name bet I thought I just did
watch she'll leo this is extremely long
credits my when I was getting myself
into short tempered thank you for
everything you do
appeared to inspire me to make daily and
thank you enough that's cool man ty
Bloomberg fan since happy wheel Oh smile
everything I dream to have an awkward
handshake with you Monday
please don't know L elevate oh hey oh I
mean I please handshake is what I meant
reverse shoutouts to PewDiePie I think
it's awesome you take time to do these
streams hang out with us I mean you're
not jacksepticeye but you're still cool
thank you for the backhand compliment I
agree
but yeah thank you appreciate you
robbing of asgaard thank you appreciate
Josh riggings they appreciate you phrase
can you stew in my stream tonight I
don't know what that means I'm sorry
B possum drunk as a skunk in Australia
yeah you must be it's not even that late
and what's the time in Australia
Australia Australia this is a fun stream
am i cutting in and out or a my audio
[ __ ]
it's my compressor I think the screams
are cool like when intros feel like mmm
a connected thing than just what you
play do you have a good spot if I play a
list to recommend I don't use Spotify
that much anymore
you should probably unsubscribe no still
there's there's album coming out
eventually
I tend to use sound [ __ ]
SoundCloud more these days but I go or
sometimes ban cam I don't really have
if I almost Spotify I'll listen to an
album like gorillas latest or a Kendrick
Kendrick Lamar thanks for doing the
content you're awesome thank you for
hanging out daily dingo shades yeah now
a lot GG thanks for the stream you're
amazing has enjoyed it I was fun for
vodka connected I finished in alright
hey you Mega Buster my last for today
but I forgot to say thank you for
everything you've done for us bro SH
hope to improve my content and use your
book to motivate myself just follow
that's what my mom tells me old
references to pray appreciate yo mega
that's very nice okay I think we're all
subscribe to your channel because you're
cool here we go
what we're just stranded we were never
on a boat just stranded thank you for
playing
luck
we were on an island in the Sun you
would play my mic still cutting it
shouldn't be doing that well that was
definitely worth the credits it's a boat
it's underwater I guess so
I would explain that Dan as we say in
Swedish oh babe what a fantastic game
great I'm showing all my porn god damn
it alright let's get back to normal no
chill for a couple minutes and then I'll
be out we got some super chance PE r xj
beam you're joining streams lately could
you keep up the work could you maybe
give me a shout-out
sure hope with this haps I love her most
Australian check out PA PE rxj everyone
top of the morning to ya
[Laughter]
okay pretty Gibson thank you for
everything you do especially for
fighting through some [ __ ] you went
through to keep it on your channel love
your videos and watch all the [ __ ]
time
thank you totally that's very nice of
you you worship me going thank you for
all the contents I don't use adblock
thank you for that can you play the
audio from your karaoke videos hell no
welcome ailing Lyn I enjoyed it come so
much I love your gameplay I love
watching your blocks when you and
mindset go on trips and I love your
pugazh fellow pocket owner here nice you
can have Edgar if you want I'm just
kidding we love you using your chore
money please shout out complicates shout
out to copper I got to publish a video
should we publish a video like we did
yesterday keep an eye out for on Nick
Seeley its prophecy very short rich hope
you're interested what is it where a
story which is that it's not out yet is
it because I google it and nothing shows
up where are the tips on getting known
well I don't know cross-promotion and
[ __ ] I guess I don't know
beg for beg for shoutouts on this stream
great live stream hey I'm a young artist
on Instagram could you check me out and
tell me what you think GLH underscore
art that's some cool [ __ ] man that's
some real cool [ __ ] looks dope looks
scary looks spooky
I like cool Gabe keep it up hey Kwon hey
pills I just started YouTube and I was
wondering if I could get a shadow
shout-out to a a Quon le again elevate
the halo again my god a pooty-poo
50 more for an
we're always saying my name wrong how do
you guys live elevate a hey yo there you
go I said it right that time
it's totally fine makes me laugh Alyssa
Twitter for my tease my never-ending
just now what what are you disappointed
about girl fine for a bit all right
Vicky Johnson love your personality
thank you for the great content never
changed and just be you keep being
fabulous lucky Thank You Vicky or vichy
sorry for murdering everyone's name
apparently hey Felix hope opposite
morgue may I support for 300 Sean Miller
and Alan killer we didn't document tired
for a tome Hill I mean Astoria never
caught on the collar puddin oh I'll been
of course I remember you
that's cool I'm gonna see that you
wanted to make movies right do I
remember you correctly like [ __ ] I hope
I don't let me check
yes I remember you all been but your
story is incredible so you you were in
an accident with fire right because of a
costume comment I hope you're doing well
it was it was really fun hanging out
with you you guys should check out our
ben youssef son it's really cool bro
appreciate chair that's cool that's cool
I'm glad to hear from you again in a
while Bryan Brito bass Bates Peter
you're my inspiration and your channel
is the first thing that I check every
day greetings from the Dominican
Republic I would love to go to the
Dominican Republic hip it's love the
screens been abroad since 2012 honestly
my grades have probably suffered because
of you don't tell me that that makes me
feel terrible hey Piz me and my
girlfriend are huge fans love your
content she's having a rough week can
you give her karlie karlie stout and
Kali stout you get a shout out you're
welcome from Ryan Hale of the streams
even though always late can you give me
a small shout I'm guessing you want to
shout out shout out to shadow storm no
I'm making it but wouldn't what oh no
I'm making it wouldn't come out for a
bed just oh yeah because it's pronounced
on Nixle I'm the video game developer
from the other day my bad that's alright
that's cool I remember now keep an eye
out for on nixels prophecy very shortly
yeah I want to play it Jai mich me -
Marty
brofist from ending prophets back to you
India
hey it's damn been John but I probably
made your name to last for today thank
you so much for amazing content brofist
and good night from India good night
India huh hope you enjoyed preciate you
PE rxj ten extra for you Felix preciate
I started watching
Richie Morty because of you and I
[ __ ] love it I want to rewatch it I
watched all the Rick & Morty episodes
okay everyone was like oh he missed all
the and the references
he's a fake fan i watch i watched it
okay I love riggan why it's this I was a
long time ago I don't remember I won't
need to re-watch it I guess I am a fake
fan I ate a sub appreciate you for
always making good Vince appreciate you
right back welcome mirror mini suit ah
hey pills appreciate your work and the
way you approach social things and
culture with the comedy keep it up okay
thank you I really appreciate that I
mean I've been getting into like more
social commentary I guess lately it's
good fun hey puss any recent anime
recommendation [ __ ] I I don't have
anything reason I really enjoy tag on
tight and season two's listen it's
really good it keeps me on edge man
Craig ball you should have hold a film
night live stream featuring the room
that would be awesome thanks for the
stream just wandering right are you
gonna stream next uh someone recommended
that a stream biding of issac that might
be fun I will do that but I I don't want
to be too late today Samuel Cox fell
asleep last night with my laptop while
you were streaming pray woke up to your
screaming little nightmares
me and my best friend Lucas have been
bonded boning over your bids bonding
over here it's for you that's cool
that's cool
mine you guys are too nice right I can't
handle it alright I'm gonna I'm gonna
probably [ __ ] off now
hey Felix like everything you do is stay
true thank you Peter pie like gusta el
panty I know what you made me say there
and I don't appreciate that Abbi shake
because it's true and I don't want
people to find out Ian campus Felix you
the man no you the man
Ian Campos Stream The Witcher 3
it's a really cool game hello Pierre
come to Taiwan Taiwan food is great that
would be cool I would love to go to
Taiwan and has some time on food ahmed
al subedi
thank you for streaming on weekend itch
five days four streams four outlets and
walking dead though totally worth it
though have a great weekend let's be
friends on Instagram please a j-20 to go
bill you and I won't make any promises
alright guys thank you for joining I had
a lot of fun you guys are cool it's
always good hangout bye good bye now
bye bye brofist alright rebus yeah